packed with quick cooking tips know-how
and 100 recipes to take your life on now
it's all about real fast food
real fast food should always grab your
attention with big gutsy flavors
fantastic Aromas and be immediately
satisfying
it should also be easy to make and quick
to cook and real fast food doesn't get
much faster than my first dish
chicken stir fry with rice noodles some
of the best street food I've ever eaten
was in Asia every one of those little
markets was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an Asian staple noodles learn to cook
those properly and you'll be surprised
how quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner
first off we're going to soak our
noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water over the
rice noodles soak
and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got to Wok perfect if not just a normal
size frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin and to cut it into strips take
your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half okay sort of
scallop
like that we call this butterfly in the
chicken take a rolling pin
and listen gently roll over the chicken
what it does it sort of flattens it
allows you to slice it even thinner
and the thinner a slice of the chicken
the sort of crisper it gets the quicker
it Cooks slice it in half
start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily
next wash your knife and finely slice
garlic
[Music]
the thinner the garlic the crispier
this is a young
tender broccoli just slice them down
I want a bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables and one third of your protein
chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil get a pan really nice and
ready
just starting to smoke drop the chicken
in first
salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
[Music]
nice
once you've started to sear off the
chicken get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
[Music]
to see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because it colors
and Cooks at the same time as well
really really crucial
now that garlic is getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
still strange putting raw broccoli in
like that normally we'll Blanchard and
boiling water dry it out but you want
that crunch
now soy sauce that helps to season it
but also stains beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
it's exactly what I want now take that
out
give you a pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
what really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing this quick stir fry very
classic two eggs in
whisk up the eggs
give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it at the side of the pan
lightly seasoned
seasoned the eggs noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
and give that
a really nice mix
I want the egg to sort of almost bring
the dish together
that egg's cooked
[Music]
make sure you've got that nice even
distribution of
chicken broccoli garlic lovely
[Music]
and then just finish that that fresh
lime
and they have a very simple
delicious stir fry with rice noodles
[Music]
noodles are fast food staple and they
come in all shapes and sizes they're so
easy to cook healthy but really
delicious here are three effortless
recipes that are ready literally in
minutes
first up noodle soup with poached egg
and spring onions
[Music]
I've miso paste the boiling water
Japanese misum has a wonderful deep
Savory richness and is brilliant in
soups
great in fresh ginger
add dry shiitake mushrooms that have
been soaked in water
season with soy sauce
crack an egg add it to the broth and
poach for two to three minutes
a thinly sliced portobello mushrooms to
a serving Bowl
put in fresh medium egg noodles which
will heat through in the hot miso broth
add spinach
then simply spoon the broth into your
bowl
with the egg
fresh chopped spring onions
good and so delicious ready in 10
minutes super fast noodle soup with
poached egg and spring onions
my next easy dish using the versatile
noodle is stir-fried pork noodles
[Music]
first marinade pork mince and shaoxing
rice wine a fortified Chinese wine
soy sauce and sesame oil
next fight chopped ginger in hot olive
oil
and garlic
next add Szechuan peppercorns which have
a wonderful lemony flavor and gives a
pleasant tingling sensation
now add your marinated pork mince
and brown
if you want more seasoning add extra soy
sauce
then add fiery chili bean paste
and rice wine vinegar
[Music]
adding cooked egg noodles
mixed together
finally top with chopped spring onion
and toasted sesame seeds
[Music]
the flavor and on the table in 15
minutes delicious stir-fried pork
noodles
my next noodle dish you can knock up in
no time is noodles with chili ginger and
lemongrass
[Music]
add chopped onions to hot olive oil
garlic
chili
and Fry
great in ginger
next lemongrass first bash it with a
knife doing this will help release this
wonderful lemony flavor and scent
now aromatic kaffir lime leaves then
ground cumin coriander and turmeric
next add cream coconut
chicken stock
fish sauce
and simmer
soaked rice vermicelli noodles in hot
water
[Applause]
drain
and add to your serving Bowl
pour over the aromatic soup broth
finish with coriander
and chopped chili
on the table in around 20 minutes
noodles with chili ginger and lemongrass
real fast food
fast healthy delicious free mouthwashing
recipes guaranteed to help you master
the art of incredible tasting noodles
next five more of my 100 top tips to
make your home cooking easier first up
how to join the chicken for your
favorite real fast food dishes
open up the legs and just pierce the
skin there careful not to cut into the
breasts and hand on top of the breast
and pull the drum back pop out
and then slice the knife
straight across
there's a thigh there's the drum get
your thumb and feel the joint and with
the weight of the knife just slices
through now two beautiful thighs
now a bit of a chef's tip halfway down
the drum just sliced through
onto the bone
and then from there
scrape up the tendons and then hand down
nice and firm on top
now
look at this beautiful bone presentation
as it Cooks It Cooks evenly now pull out
the wing feel where the end of the joint
is and just slice in there
through
a beautiful big whole delicious Wing now
this is the Rolls-Royce part two breasts
that's the breast bone there place the
chicken on the board and then just slice
down on the back of the crown
everyone always cuts around just tilt it
upwards straight through that way we get
straight to the center of the carcass
and therefore there's no waste
and look
we end up taking off his clump
chicken breasts nice two drums two
thighs two Wings two breasts of chicken
and one amazing carcass for a stock and
not an ounce of waste
a great tip to stop your skewers burning
when you're making kebabs is to soak
them in water first or for skills with
added flavor strip your Rosemary
branches of their leaves and use instead
[Music]
for no fuss marinating my tip is to
place fish or meat in a plastic storage
bag while they marinate it's easy to
store and there's less cleanup
lime juice or lemon juice make great
marinades my tip for getting maximum
amount of juice from a lemon or lime is
to roll it hard under your palm for a
minute before juicing
lemons are also useful for Rice add a
couple of drops of juice while you cook
it to keep your grains looking nice
white and bright
[Music]
coming up on my Ultimate Guide to real
fast food more great kitchen tips now
the secret of a good barbecue sauce is
that really important caramelization
what to look for and the best
ingredients and a Twist on a fast food
classic guaranteed never to let you down
I'll take that over a hamburger any day
[Music]
My ultimate cookery course 100 recipes
to stake your life on I'll be showing
you how to make mouthwashing burgers
with a difference pork is perfect for a
slider but I want a little bison there
but first my guide to getting the best
ingredients for your money
whether I'm knocking out fast food or
planning a feast I want my dishes to be
the tastiest they can be and to do that
I always start with the best ingredients
I can get
my shopping Mantra is very simple
knowledge is crucial the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
so ask lots of questions and learn
foreign
[Music]
of the six most useful vinegars and what
you can do with them all make great fast
and easy dressings with the exception of
malt vinegar use this for pickling or
splashing on your fish and chips Tangy
red wine vinegar is great for marinades
red meats and calves liver white wine
vinegar is good for sweet and sour
recipes as well as butter sauces
Cherry vinegar nutty and virgin on the
sweet side this perfect Splash into
gazpacho or team with sweet seasoned veg
like asparagus or artichokes
while cider vinegar tart and fruity is
ideal for pickling fruit and for
vegetable chutneys
rice vinegar is an essential for Chinese
and Japanese dishes and is lovely and
Mild in flavor
balsamic vinegar widely considered as a
king of vinegars it's the one I use time
and time again dark and syrupy it's
sweet and sharp taste is a great
addition if you're frying juicy steaks
or chops in marinades or on fresh sweet
strawberries
like fine wine the price reflects the
time it's been matured anywhere between
3 and 25 years look out for the stem to
make sure you're getting the genuine
article from Italy's modern region you
can pay up to 200 quid for just 100 ml
of top quality bathroom vinegar like
this one
and if you do Splash out on one of the
fine types you'll have to taste it to
believe it
[Music]
there's a wealth of classic fast food
dishes we know and love from hot dogs
and kebabs to tacos and burgers but the
great thing about making them at home is
you can throw away the rule book and get
creative
my next easy recipe is a miniature
version of an American favorite the
burger Smoky Pork sliders with barbecue
sauce everyone loves a burger they're a
true fast food original and that's the
exciting thing about street food you can
take an old classic like that and
reinvent it into something really
exciting
what do you think of a burger what you
need is a great sauce and I like Smoky
Barbecue it goes hand in glove with a
great burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
ice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
nice seasoning salt and pepper now the
secret of a good barbecue sauce is that
really important caramelization to begin
with a nice tablespoon brown sugar
it darkens the onions but it really
starts to sort of give that nice syrupy
body to the sauce
I'll put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you've got to cook them out
and always sort of burn off that rawness
especially with the smoked paprika
that's exactly where I want it to go
onions and garlic beautifully
caramelized
[Music]
I've cider vinegar in
reduce that down
now I've got a fantastic Smoky base to
complete the sauce I'm making my life
really easy and adding pre-made
Worcester sauce and tomato ketchup cut
that out for two to three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce that term is how long you
cook it out for I don't want it to be
too runny but I don't want to be too
thick either
that's the consistency we're looking for
mmm
lovely
turn down the gas
now take that out
it's the kind of sauce that I like to
have sort of bottled up in the fridge
it's great for sandwiches
because brilliantly well with these
sliders homemade Smoky Barbecue sauce
[Music]
look at the panel it wipe now to start
the mix for the sliders to give my mix a
really interesting flavor and texture
I'm going to be using unsmoked baked
bacon I travel all over the world
and I spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders bee sliders chicken sliders
it's almost like a way of having a
burger
but on a much smaller miniature level
a little teaspoon of olive oil I want
that bacon to get really nice and crispy
bacon in
this just gives the really nice sort of
chunky delicious mix I want texture and
pork is perfect for a slider
[Music]
and chocolate
's a lot sweeter than your normal white
onion
fine fine fine and in
[Music]
now that Bacon's getting really nice and
crispy I want a bit of heat in the
little teaspoon
smoke Paprika in there and we see these
Sliders in the states for one portion
there's like four or five of them little
mini
One Bites incredible now take your pork
let's open up
and give that a really nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so season it nicely
bacon now that's nice and crispy
just take a little touch
ing right and just drain that off that
[Music]
nice
Pat that nice and dry I want all that
nice sort of crispiness
in there beautiful mix all that in take
a nice ball and sort of roll it
size of a golf ball
get it nice and round first and then
three fingers
Pat that down
don't flatten them too thin otherwise be
overcook and they go sort of dry
the slide is a bite-sized Burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot tablespoon of
olive oil when a slider is literally
that thick about an inch thick we're
going to take two and a half to three
minutes each side in
turn them over
lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoons
all that juice back into them keep my
mouth watering now
so easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now with your fingers is nice
and firm the little touch of springiness
in the center I'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted I'm using wedges or smoked
cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess to the slider
finally shredded baby gem lettuce
and just take those buns make sure
they're sliced
nice and evenly take your lettuce be
quite generous with the lettuce it's a
nice thin slice
tomato
take your burgers
you see that cheese
if you've melted your barbecue sauce
play top on
and that is my version of a slider that
is small Dynamic but packed full of
flavor I'll take that over a hamburger
any day
[Music]
right now it's all about making it easy
making it easy for yourself in the
kitchen means using the time you have
effectively and the one thing that can
really help you do that is your freezer
[Music]
my recipe for meatballs is so versatile
it can be used to make a dozen amazing
dishes
one of my favorites is meatballs and
fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home-cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
life saver it means you never have to
compromise on Flavor these meatballs are
delicious but more importantly they
freeze so well
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off the onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs in a classic way but the
exciting part
is actually cook them in coconut milk
and it gives a really nice new dimension
to a sort of soft Rich Sumptuous
meatball
chop the onion nice and finely keeping
those slices very close together close
to the slices the finer the onions
Pat it back down at an angle slice down
and just chop
want the onions nice and fine because I
want some finesse to these meatballs The
Secret of a really good meatball is the
texture getting that balance right
between the minced beef the bread crumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple cloves of
garlic slice of garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous with the olive
oil
onions and garlic in a little touch of
salt and pepper
[Music]
with your mince open it up a little bit
and sort of cut it out that's salt
and pepper
for me a good meatball is all about the
the softness the texture of that Rich
beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside
but you want it nice and soft and sort
of rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then place it back out again I've
got some really nice dried chili flakes
I'm going to season the onions with the
chili flakes chili flakes in
cook that out for two minutes I'm gonna
add some milk
[Music]
take your breadcrumbs make a little well
three four tablespoons of milk that
makes a sort of nice slightly doughy
texture but it lightens the texture of
the meatball
place that in
add your onions your garlic and your
chili in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs it doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small
the problem with making them too small
is the fact that they dry out quickly
just the size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
looking really nice tight squeeze that
stops IT from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time give the pan a
little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavor from the onions the garlic at the
bottom look at that pan nice and hot
Touch of olive oil in there
place them
at the top of your pan
nice and gently
sit them in the oil
get a palette knife and go underneath
them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're going to add
some heat coriander seeds slightly spicy
and peppery also give a really nice
flavor to the coconut milk in next some
cardamon seeds three or four onto the
board knife on
then a little touch of turmeric into the
center of the pan that's going to give
it a really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch cinnamon
all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier a couple of dried chilies let
them Infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of Beat It
Down that starts to release all that
lovely sort of fragrance like someone's
just let off the most amazing fragrant
air freshener in for the lemongrass
finally some fresh ginger
peel
it's nice nice and thinly
time now
to turn them over
and let the other half for a wonderful
flavor
chicken stock in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
I want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the top of a meatball
coconut milk in
and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
a nice soft texture of the meatball but
that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth it's going to cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
then simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
[Music]
touch them with your finger they should
be slightly pliable but slightly springy
gas off I'm gonna finish it off with
something light and fresh zest of lime
but I want the zest
on top of the meatball so I'll cut
through that richness and then finally
squeeze fresh lime
and that just gives it that nice zesty
amazing taste
stirring the juice
it's got that kick in that
vibrant taste now the exciting part
when you come to serve it be generous
with that coconut broth
till the pan
get a good couple of ladles of a broth
in
meatballs
[Music]
and that is a very
delicious way of eating a old-fashioned
meatball and bringing it into the 21st
century and they're just as good cooked
from Frozen as well
[Music]
the secret to stress-free cooking is
making it easy for yourself here are
three more recipes all based on my
delicious freezer friendly meatballs
just defrost them before you get started
first up beef meatballs without a kitty
kale and pine nuts
[Applause]
[Music]
add meatballs to Hot Oil
and brown
meanwhile cook allocated pasta
then add chopped garlic to the meatballs
and shredded kale a delicious green veg
packed with vitamins which Cooks in
minutes cabbage is a great alternative
if you can't get kale
put in some of the cooking water from
the pasta to steam through
when the pasta is cooked al dente drain
and add to the meatballs season
then finish with sweet buttery pine nuts
and grated fresh parmesan cheese
meatballs with olive keti kale and pine
nuts from meatballs to meal in minutes
my next easy standby supper is beef
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa
[Music]
top a lightly Toasted Roll with
pan-fried meatballs then tear off chunks
of creamy buffalo mozzarella pile it on
and melt it under the grill
for the Tangy salsa sliced sweet red
onion then add juicy diced tomatoes and
roughly chop fresh coriander
season and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a Flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich to die for
[Music]
my final super easy meatball recipe is
fiery meatball soup
[Music]
fried chopped onion and finely sliced
garlic in hot olive oil
add cumin seeds for warmth
and add your meatballs
cook on a high heat to get all those
aromatic flavors out
once the meatballs are browned add hot
chili paste for a spicy kick tinned
tomatoes
dried oregano and a liter of beef stock
[Music]
then simmer
next add sweet corn
and chopped courgettes
[Music]
to finish add hot jalapeno peppers chop
fresh coriander and crushed tortilla
chips
a one-pot meatball wonder that really
packs a punch firing meatball soup
[Music]
one versatile meatball recipe four
deliciously different dishes food that's
certain to make your life in the kitchen
easier and stress-free amazing whether
you're making great food to freeze or to
take straight to the table you need to
know how to shop for the best
ingredients next up my shopping guide to
oils
it doesn't matter if you're baking
frying or dressing salads using the
right oil can dramatically alter The
Taste and texture
here are the most common oils and what
to use them for
sunflower oil is a good value
all-rounder nice and light for frying
bacon in dressings and spicy dishes
but or peanut oil is great for cooking
on high heat as it gets really hot
without burning
sesame oil I flavor some sweet and nutty
oil perfect sprinkled over Asian dishes
before serving
rapeseed oil is a healthier choice for
using in salads
I love walnut oil fantastically fragrant
it's brilliant for salad dressings and
it gives cakes a distinctive flavor
oil are used most in my cooking is olive
oil
[Music]
to find some of the best olive oils sold
in Britain you have to go to one of the
most unlikely places
an electrical shop in London's East End
turkish-born Mehmet morat has olive oil
in his blood my families produce this
olive oil for centuries what he doesn't
know about it isn't worth knowing
the very best extra virgin olive oil is
first cold pressed it's actually pressed
by Stone and then it's put for a
centrifugal spinner which spins out all
the bitter Waters and then you've got
your pure olive oil cold pressed olive
oil and you've got to taste it to
believe it
pour a little sample
slurp it draw it in without don't
swallow it warm it in your mouth coat
the whole of the inside of your mouth
with it and then swallow it'll go down
like fruit juice and it will leave no
grease in a solar oiliness in your mouth
whatsoever
absolutely Sensational beautiful
my favorite use of any olive oils is to
pour it into a bowl room temperature rub
some wild oregano into it and get some
fresh crusty bread and just dip it
there's food on its own don't eat
anything else
coming up on my guide to making it easy
more simple but Dependable tips give
that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a bit lighter
slightly fluffy my take on the ultimate
bacon must-haves these three items are
so cheap yet they are so important it's
a great home cooking and a
mouth-watering variation of the classic
brownie once it's cooled down take it
out and start slicing
[Music]
foreign welcome back to my ultimate
cookery course
next are my guide to making it easy I'll
be creating a sweet treat to drool over
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around but first
my quick guide to the basic kit you need
to get cooking fantastic food
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment
here are three more Kitchen Essentials
whisk spoon and spatula
these three items are so cheap yet they
are so important to Great home cooking
a whisk there's so much more control
when you've got something whisking in
your hand you can gauge it so much
better than you can if it's an electric
mixer
bigger the balloon on your hand whisk
the faster it will whip as it draws in
more air Wooden Spoons don't scratch
pans I should be washed by hand spatulas
are indispensable for baking or mixing
sure it's heat resistant so it doesn't
melt but more importantly phenomenal for
making
omelettes great with scrambled eggs and
you waste nothing because the spatula
almost cleans the bowl instantly
with these three you'll be well on your
way to cooking like a pro
and you'll need all three for my next
recipe
[Music]
my take on classic chocolate brownies is
guaranteed to put a smile on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
blondies
stock up on these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead if you're
expecting guests around
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version I.E blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
gently melt that butter Castle sugar
into the bowl
let's give that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a bit lighter
slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make a
little well in the middle
and sort of whisk you see
it's already got nice and blonde
love it
give back
a really good mix
[Music]
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
lovely
a teaspoon of vanilla extract in
next lightning whisk and two whole eggs
let's give it a little beat
this is such a delicious recipe yeah
it's so simple whisk in the eggs looking
for that nice sort of Rich texture
smooth paste
see why we call these blondies beautiful
next teaspoon of baking powder baking
powder in then half a teaspoon of baking
soda
periods the mixture it gives it that
little tartness you'll see this sort of
Rise instantly the minute they hit the
oven
and then your flour whisk with one hand
just
slowly at half the flower first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it occasionally
no lumps half a flowering
and then the other half in you'll feel
it sort of almost nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flowering stages it stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the Whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon next
I want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies dried
cranberries
they bake beautifully but it gives the
Blondie a really nice sort of chewy
sweetness in the center next
and white chocolate
I'm not gonna grate it let's chop it up
just slice it like little bits of
shrapnel
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
chocolate in lovely fold that in I want
a nice even distribution of those
wonderful dried cranberries
don't over mix it I want to break up
that chocolate
a nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate
see the chocolate there'll be parts of
the chocolate in the oven that will
actually melt
and be like little pools of white melted
chocolate in the center
now
baking tray
small little knob of butter
and the grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just over
extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
grease proof allows me to maximize on
the white chocolate inside the mix no
grease with paper the chocolate can melt
and almost stick to the tray so the
paper is just a really nice insurance
policy secondly won't that rise and that
sort of crispness now with the mix get
your spatula all the way around I don't
want to see anything left in that bowl
position the ball over your tray
nice and carefully
lovely
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one and then just
take the back of the spatula go into the
corners push and come back into the
middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it Cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
Blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise it's nice and crisp
on that soft gooiness in the center
bake your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
[Music]
that smells incredible
look at that crisp Edge on the outside
in that sort of soft gooey Center leave
that to cool down and it's going to sort
of firm up and wrinkle but it'll stay
nice and gooey in the center once it's
cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
mouth-watering blondies a fantastic easy
treat to have on hand for yourself or to
share
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips to make your life easier make sure
you make the most of your freezer my tip
for amazing tuna carpaccio is to freeze
it first and it will slice beautifully
it's wise to save leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine and freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces
[Music]
when you freeze soups or stews in tubs
the tip is not to overfill them leave
room to expand in the container
[Music]
for a cheap homemade ice cream buy a
high quality vanilla ice cream and make
it your own by mixing in berries
chocolate or my favorite rum and boozy
raisins
[Music]
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes they won't
water down your drink and they'll also
add flavor
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips 100 recipes to stay your life
on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
foreign